I've got Wendy here on the line wendy is
calling in from Massachusetts Wendy how
are you I'm sorry yeah I won focus and
not finish young lady what's on your
mind today my question is so my daughter
is a junior in college and she got into
some really good schools which we
couldn't afford so she's going to the
state school and she took out a FAFSA
loan so by the time she graduates will
be about $20,000 in debt and I went back
to work so I could cover the rest of her
tuition but I've been able to save about
$14,000 so by the time she graduates I
should have enough to pay off her debt
these worked really hard and she saved
about ten thousand so my question is do
I pay off her debt or is that
undermining her like and why so cuz she
worked so hard but I don't want to sort
of you know pull the rug out from
underneath them do you work so hard but
I'm gonna pay it off anyway or don't you
or is that I guess what why is she
working is she working hard to attack
and pay those off herself okay
she works the occasions not during the
school year okay working she stressed
about the debt she is okay well you know
what here's the thing so you've gone
back to work but before we get to that
let me hit the stop sign tell me first
Wendy how do you all what's your
financial situation look like how much
do you all have saved for retirement um
okay so this is where the complexities
come in that I didn't understand when my
parents did their estate planning
they put a large property into my name
okay but then when she went apply to
colleges made my net worth so high that
we didn't get any money except I don't
get any of your money from the property
are your parents still alive
yeah okay so let me ask you again Wendy
how much do you have saved for
retirement I have about a million okay
all right
and what now you own your home free and
clear Wow I'll say I like you already
alright we're doing some stuff here now
alright see this is a different
complexity now what do you owe on do you
have any debt let's try one more time
Wendy did you paused
you have a car loan no okay do you own
anything else right now I have a credit
card bill of a thousand dollars which I
will pay off
I felt the guilt over the phone line you
know that I got intuition I got feel it
Wendy
now listen pay that thing off and get
that thing out of your life quit messing
around
get back here to your daughter number
one see you all have trained her the
fact that she feels a little stress
about this debt I don't think is a bad
thing I really don't and I love the fact
that you are looking at it and you're
care enough you want your daughter to
start off on the right foot here's what
could happen let's think let's go down
two paths let's say she does continue to
work and she pays off that debt how's
she gonna feel about herself I think
she's gonna feel empowered I think she's
gonna feel empowered she's gonna feel
like she did this and lo and behold what
if as she graduates you have some money
that you're able to give to her as a
graduation present you see where I'm
going with this yeah see I think it can
be twofold number one she did this she
paid off her student loans and so for
her in her mind she's got the feeling of
what debt feels like she knows that
weight on her shoulders and that's
what's pushing her so I don't think we
take away this growth opportunity for
her because she's gonna learn some
things but I still think you have an
opportunity to be a blessing for her and
to be able to gift her with that money
as a as a graduation gift maybe you buy
our car maybe that's something you kick
off and she's got an emergency fund
there are two ways but I like the path
of this young lady being as focused as
she is that means you all have trained
her and you've talked to her about money
let's let her keep growing I don't think
there's anything wrong with that I think
in America today our goal as parents is
to help people to grow up to be
productive citizens to
often times we try to make sure that our
kids don't ever have any struggle and if
they never get a chance to have struggle
they don't ever get a chance to kind of
learn and grow and we'll never get a
chance to flex muscles to find out what
they can withstand and to learn some
lessons and so we gotta let them we got
to let them feel that we got to let them
push now I didn't say struggle
unnecessarily but not all struggle is a
bad thing struggle will help you find
out who you are and help you to
understand more of what you say
you truly believe so Wendy I think this
is a good thing let her keep pushing I
think she's got a lot of things that she
can learn from this process and I'm
proud of you and Wendy pay off that
credit card and shut that thing down
okay I want you send me a message when
you do it get that thing out her life
you're an everyday Millionaire honey you
ain't got time for that